[Musik]
wir bringen
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu uns verliebt weil
es heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
menü den wir werden gut in der lage
machen mit kartoffeln und eigentlich ist
sogar fast die klassische variante nur
mit einer ausnahme will neben stadt homs
getötet
leute jahren die awo schmeckt wirklich
super lecker und wir alle machen
kartoffeln später mit dazu und ich mag
wohl sowieso ganz gerne denn man kann
sie zubereiten und dann gebe ich sie zum
sparen in den backofen und in der zeit
in den backofen kommt kann ich nicht
fertig machen kann in vier schritten
kann nur unterhalten
beim aufräumen und im fünfte ist dann
das essen fertig und franca neben
gegessen werden so rouladen sind auch
die absprachen er ist ein zwischen
politischem geschick an ihren ganzen
klose fällt und dirigent ganz klassisch
weiß schon was auch touristik seien es
nur schwachen sportlichen großen
sportarten genau diese friedlich
schmorgerichte und es ist ein typisch
österreichisch deutsch schweizer
veterinär rouladen in österreich aber
auch links vögel im streitfall nicht und
in ontario ist da um änderungen ich
einfach nur war ausgerollt wird
naja egal ist manches flugdaten dafür
brauche ich zwei etlichen fotos lang 57
eine karotte vier esslöffel sind etwa 20
cornish und als kleine brücken
hier habe ich etwas wärmer und zwar in
washington habe ich acht rouladen vom
cent und für die soße brauche ich dann
noch einen halben punkt auf stangen
sterbefälle zwei karotten 750 milliliter
flüssigkeit haben die kinder vor und in
durchweg trocken flüssigkeit und
natürlichkeit und verfahren zuerst
einmal wie zwiebelkuchen internet
vorbereitet werden und kann die zwiebeln
jetzt von manchen oben
hier habe ich eine scheibe drin und was
die fäden im ganzen
feine ringe schneiden geht natürlich
auch mit messer aber so bin ich einfach
ein bisschen schneller und getriebe
schreiben sind auch gleichmäßig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als nächstes die kochen auch in feine
scheiben schneiden
es gibt auch ein messer oder eben auch
mit der küchenmaschine
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich will mich noch die karotte und je
nach größe können wir dann schütteln und
dann noch in feine streifen schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt können die rouladen befüllt werden
dafür nimmt jetzt ein stück fleisch und
legt es der länge nach vor euch hin
streichen sie jetzt mit etwa einem
halben teelöffel wenn ich weiß was du
selbst nimmt ja im prinzip kann jeder
teilnehmen
denn am liebsten mag ich nimmt auch
gerne immer extra scharfen senf aber die
kinder ist und später noch mit daher
mich jetzt nur ein mittel schaffen
wollen der war ganz gut ich mag das
gerade führen auch keine gurken
eigentlich verlaufen wie vor längerer
bremsweg lassen die menschen die guten
willens den rouladen jetzt mit weißem
pfeffer würzen
vielleicht auch nicht zu arg willst du
denn jetzt kommt noch fast immer dazu
und fast immer das hat hier außen so
eine dünne statement heißt es auf
türkisch und weitere knoblauch passte
mit ganz vielen vorn geworfen und da
lediglich jeweils etwa eineinhalb seiten
rein und belegt die rouladen jetzt auch
nur so etwa zu zwei dritteln kommt der
schöne park gekommen für die kurze zeit
diese kämen dürften bockshornklee genau
heißt gehört und das ist dann auch echt
ganz typischer fachfirma jetzt kommen
hier noch die karotten reichen einfach
mitwippen und die bringen hat noch ein
bisschen farbe mit rheine finde ich ganz
schön und dann auch ihren 47 uhr jetzt
im prinzip wie bei gefühlten weintrauben
blättern
zuerst einmal hier am rand entwickeln
einschlagen so läuft erst mit frau und
daran dass eben auch schön und jetzt die
roulade auf rollen ganz vorsichtig auf
50 zu folgen
deswegen ist vierkampf wichtig dass
unten frei bleibt sind da kann ich bin
drauf und hab ein toller abschluss
[Musik]
eindruck
jetzt sind alle rouladen gefüllt am
schnellsten geht übrigens wenn ihr alle
gleichzeitig mache das alles einmal für
euch hinlegen alle füllen und auf rollen
und jetzt wechsel noch mit zahnstochern
zusammen da gibt da auch extra rouladen
nadeln öfter macht uns ist auf jeden
fall oder alles genau durch metall oder
auch einfach die blick aufgaben von
zusammenbinden
weil die pflanze die können aufbrechen
bevor wichtiger sein
ich will nur kohle aus im kopf haben
dass ich mal später wieder gut weg
machen bevor man es ebenso wenig später
immer schon ganz praktisch sie
profitiere in der rollladen bevor ich
sie im ofen schmoren erst anbraten und
hier habe ich jetzt mein schwarthoff
einen chauffeur und die besten leute
bekommen oft frankreich und die sind
meist aus gusseisen und gut und
natürlich sehr praktisch denn die
funktion auch auf infektions koch
feldern kochfeldern und jetzt werde ich
den sport talk erstmal erhitzen macht
zwar immer bei mittlerer hitze und dann
eben ganz den darf man ja wirklich sehr
hoch erhitzen
aber eben nicht wenn man vorne ganz
wichtig ist dass man den topf dem sport
niemals alleine ergibt also töpfe und
allgemein immer ein bisschen fett mit
rein geben und da geht es jetzt weiter
schmalz mit rein und warum wodurch man
keine schöne mutter tish war hat aber
wenn mein vater allein in dem dann
verbrennt noch profil
wahrscheinlich auf stufe fliegen wieder
runter damit aber nicht zu heiß wird und
jetzt gebe ich die rinderroulade rein
und wechsel von allen seiten richtig
schön anbraten vor entstehen nämlich die
vom rost augen
[Musik]
die rouladen machen angebraten und geht
bei twitter foto schmelz mit freien dem
da vinci knopfes gemüsereste mich
einfach mittelabruf geschnitten auch die
restlichen kriebel diesen dienst lieben
sie waren sehr groß aber das macht gar
nicht um fässer und hier werde ich hier
etwa vier bis fünf minuten angebraten
es gibt gerade aus richtig film gerüstet
um erhärten auch wenn die flüssigkeit
der langsam weg geht dann fließt es
richtig schön und am besten könnt ihr
jetzt zum beispiel bis in rotwein dazu
geben und den dann wieder schön
verdampfen lassen
so bekommt man nicht nur der geschmack
von auch ein bisschen farbenfroh beim
anbraten ist auch ganz wichtig denn so
kommen die ganzen kräftigen aromen
verstanden
ich bin jetzt hier die gemütliche
vielleicht früher auf
wird sie es noch live mit teils und
pfeffer zeichnete einfach mal
abschmecken
obwohl genug sprit wenn es sein muss mit
rein geben
[Musik]
früher darf ist aufgehoben da gebe ich
noch zwei drei laubblätter mit rein
schlägt auch immer ganz toll
fleischgerichten
und der vorteil von dem sportler bist
natürlich wird alles drin mit angefragt
was jetzt hier auf den ganzen geschmack
mit drin und gehwege rinderrouladen
wieder mit rein
falls sie aber keine top habt könnt ihr
das natürlich auch in einer heißen
pfanne zum beispiel anbraten oder in
einer spanne und das ganze dann auch bei
live erhitzen auf dem herd in einem topf
kochen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der deckel rouladen auch
schön saftig und ganz wichtig ist dass
ihr euch jetzt hand nimmt oder zu
spielen diese silikon helfer denn das
motto ist sehr heiß und so kommuniziert
im dorfladen in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 160 grad ober unterhitze
für ungefähr zwei stunden - 2 stunden
die rouladen fertig um die ziemlich
gleich hier übrigens normal ein kilo
kartoffeln weich gekocht innovative kurz
unterschieden im wasser kalt abspülen
und wieder anpeilen
jetzt gehts aber erst mal angefangen
haben und die werden jetzt erstmal auf
der große rausch ein dandy verweist
gleich noch angekommen
[Musik]
die decke ab dann bleiben sie schön warm
und trocken auch nicht aus und jetzt
werde ich in große hier erstmal raus
holen wenn ich welche durch ein sieb
streichen ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel einfach pürieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hab ich mir diese wundervolle früher
mit dem ganzen geschmacklos in den kopf
die sofort noch angelegt werden und
dafür nehme ich jetzt zwei täter für
speisestärke und etwas flüssigkeit geht
noch um geschmack
etwa ein bis zwei zähler 56
[Applaus]
um die starke mischung wird es hier ein
gehört und so kann ich jetzt hier ein
paar minuten kochen lassen dass er
einfach schön einrichtung mehr zeit
werde ich schon mal die kartoffeln
pellen und wie dann in butterschmalz
anbraten
[Musik]
die körperlichen angebraten werden die
preis und pfeffer würzen
es ist auch ein gewächs war mit fast
fragen treffen ins wasser gefallen was
uns aber trotzdem deshalb viel aus wie
mal gespannt und für den ganztag
geschmack kommt noch
also da diese sehr wahrscheinlich keinen
kalten hinter gibt es in die salzvorräte
sind voll bzw
diese künftig mehr rein macht vor
gericht einfach genial ist leicht warnt
wenn ich finde es einfach genial
die zubereitung die ganze geschichte
dahinter steckt als rein stecken zwei
stunden lang in der zeit etwas anderes
machen schon genial war somit leichter
entfernen da gerne zu gast
machen wir zusammen meine eltern kommen
vor dem servieren sagen doch ein
zahnstocher drin steckt aber ich mache
mir die arbeit mit dem plan
ich glaube da natürlich wieder töten
oder so man kann zwar gerichten von
richtig toll knödeln und rotkohl 1
aber wer uns dagegen entschieden weil
ich find die rouladen dem ofen und ich
für den wert kann man wirklich das am
wochenende funktioniert noch hinstellen
und rotkohl und knödeln war auf was ist
so lecker aus das misstrauen ist schon
fertig wohl vor die kamera heben darf
man hier warten darf und soll sexy
wahnsinn besitzt und vor allem diesmal
wo sie wohne wo man nicht ehrlich auf
tripolis gemacht so sucht wird nicht
klasse
ok also die polizei der kartoffel habe
ich alles drauf
ein laptop
die katholische und aufbereitung komisch
wirklich so aus kartoffeln vertragen und
das fleisch frau war zwölf mal und von
innen drin war und wie das passt es gibt
war wirklich ein ganz ganz toll
geschmackloses ihnen aus karotten ihr
seht die guten
das passt immer so lecker wirklich
dieses dort voll lecker wirklich leute
wie die macht ist unbedingt nach
wintermonaten auch total lecker wir
rechnen immer so etwa eine roulade pro
person und manches auch aus wie zwei
rouladen 42 machen wir aber dann
tatsächlich denn wenn man was übrig hat
kann man das auch ganz gut einfrieren
oder eben am nächsten tag essen dem
rathaus hier ein gut man wirklich
deutlich in europa nämlich auch ubisoft
nach machen wollt dann geht auch findet
- das steht noch mal ganz genau und ich
bin zuerst einmal ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen unsere bilder vom letzten mal
schauen wir zu anderen schmorgerichte
ankömmling und alle wirklich für alle
male war genial
ende
[Musik]